what often distinguishes fulfilled from
unfulfilled lives is an ingredient
that's not part of the educational
curriculum and that can solve a zillion
californian in the bad sense confidence
it's humbling to realize just how many
great achievements haven't been the
result of superior talent or technical
know-how merely that strange buoyancy of
the soul that we call confidence why is
confidence so easy to lack partly it's a
hangover from the past for thousands of
years for most of us there simply were
no opportunities for hope we were serfs
and slaves and the central psychological
survival skill was to keep our heads
down and our expectations low each of us
still carries a little of the legacy
from that past an attitude of inner
serfdom that threatens our spirit deep
into a democratic technological modern
age hope can feel dangerous there might
in addition have been parents who sent
out subtle messages people like ask
don't who do you take yourself for we
should feel compassionate about where
those defensive parental messages came
from they were a protection a survival
strategy and an escape from humiliation
school didn't necessarily help either it
wanted us to be good boys and girls and
taught us to trust in established
Authority but we may not have gone on
too long
putting too much faith in existing
institutions and now suffer from doing
whatever is asked of us a little too
obediently part of becoming an adult
seems to be to embrace the painful
realization that grown-ups don't
actually have all the answers and
therefore that we have every right
indeed a duty to break certain rules and
think things through independently we
need to learn a calculated form of
disrespect which can be a surprising
thing after 20 years or so of enforced
obedience we need to learn a
constructive suspicion of authority a
path between total compliance on the one
hand and sullen skepticism on the other
in addition confidence seems to involve
a courage to accept in
perfection it's tempting never to get
going when everything has to be perfect
but that's a recipe for remaining under
the bed and yet how often so-called
great lives have been riddled with
errors but nevertheless didn't sink them
confidence begins with a capacity to
forgive oneself the horrors of the first
go death is a necessary thought too we
should use it not to further sad on us
but to scare us fruitfully into taking
some action our fear of messing up
should give way to the only real danger
there is that of never crying if you
like our films take a look at our shop
the school of life calm forward-slash
shop you'll find lots of thoughtful
books games stationery and more
you